Hi, I'm John Green, and this is not Crash
Course: World History because we're taking
a week off. However, we do have four episodes
of World History left. After that, we will
be done. We will be done learning about the
history of the world. We will have completed
it. We will know everything that there is
to know about world history. Congratulations.
Stan has just informed me that, apparently,
there is more world history than just what
we talked about on Crash Course: World History.
That's disappointing to learn. He also says
that some stuff happened today that we haven't
covered, and that stuff will happen tomorrow,
and et cetera…hhuuhhh. History. It just
keeps happening!
Anyway, speaking of Stan: starting in a few
weeks, Stan is going to be hosting a Crash
Course miniseries on intellectual property
and copyright law, which is hugely important
to all of us who care about making things and art and
the quality of internet, so I'm very excited for that.
Also, there's going to be Crash Course: Economics. Adrian Hill & Jacob Clifford will be teaming up to teach
you economics so that you can understand, you know, why you are oppressed by the system of capitalism.
Apparently Stan says that I can't say that.
So that you can understand why the system
of capitalism has been so beneficial to you.
Apparently Stan says I also can't say that.
I—I don't know. That's why I'm going—I'm
going to, to learn as well.
As for me, in the coming year I'll be popping
into Crash Course videos here and there, but
I have this other job, writing books. Come
to think of it, it's both an intellectual
property problem and an economics problem.
So I, I'm going to try to write a book in
the coming year, so you won't see quite as
much of me, but enjoy Crash Course: Economics
and Crash Course: Intellectual Property.
Stan says that I have to leave the frame now
so that he can enter it. Bye!
Stan: Hi, I'm Stan Muller, and I'm a real
person.
I'm very excited that this April I'm going to spend
a few weeks teaching you about intellectual property.
The idea of protecting intellectual
property has been around for a long time.
We're gonna talk about the history of IP,
how it works, and what it looks like today.
Anyway, I'm really excited to learn about all this amazing stuff with you. I'll see you in a few weeks.